في حادثه غريبه ونادره الوقوع وتضاف الى
قائمه الحوادث المروعه على متن الرحلات
الجويه تعرضت ركبه للدغه من عقرب وهي
علمتني رحله جويه على متن شركه طيران
الهند كانت متجهه من الجبور الى مومباي في
الهند في التفاصيل قالت الشركه في بيان
لها بان الركبه تعرضت لللدغ من قبل عقرب
كان على متن هذه الطائره تمت معالجه
المسافره بشكل طارئ على متن الرحله وتم
نقلها الى المستشفى بعد هبوط الطائره
وخرجت في وقت لاحق من المستشفى بصحه جيده
اكدت ان هذه الحادثه نادره ومؤسفه وان
فريق شركه الطيران اتبع البروتوكول واجرى
فحصا كاملا للطائره وجد العقرب بعد ذلك تم
تنفيذ عمليه التبخير وتطهير وعبرت الشركه
عن اسفها على المعاناه والازعاج الذي لحق
بالمسافره